[Music]
Kumasi Jeff was from dirty PDR take an
Arctic a parte del la sfera delivered
son or Mario ultra have departed le
person is a request or a destroyer roger
goodell chikara de eliminar a uncut
Reverso a Punto the participation of the
seminar in the laboratory with the
generally 10 beautiful Kenosha area
concerning an aeronaut solutions it's
just really about exchanging ideas and
being open to the different perspectives
that these different authors might have
visibility is always key so who belongs
to the stage what what kind of bodies
belongs to the contemporary downstage
what voices are being heard and what
identities are being seen so we wanted
to extend that idea as to who who does
the stage belong to this is the
beginning of something that can get
really much bigger than I thought
[Music]
the International aspect of it is really
important because we also gain ideas and
input from how the different artists
might work in different context where in
their own countries so it also allows us
to not become insular it also opens up
for professional development I think and
for your own artistic practice to grow
it's very important because we don't
want the stagnation in arts we always
want to develop and crew to bring in new
ideas artists from different cultures
and we also have come in our house with
a different repertoire of movement of
ideas political ideas in the UK there
are a lot more further in in how they
work on inclusive dance and so there's a
lot more knowledge about it it's
important to work internationally
because we can learn a lot from each
other but also we are building at the
same goal and to make dance more
inclusive and together I think we are
stronger often in theater and dance that
people who are not excluded reflect on
the exclusion of others for me it's one
possibility but it's not enough to bring
together all those those people who
didn't know each other before and to
make a process together with them work I
think if we only take this process of
the laboratories if there will be five
laboratories and five different cities
and many of the disabled artists will
come back and meet again and I think
it's that's already an amazing process
because very little of them are touring
usually it's it's often it's very local
work and that's a big thing
for me these moments are very precious
where you bring together artists from
all across Europe with all these
different life experiences and different
work that they may I need to meet all of
these different artists around the world
to fill up with energy to fill up with
inspiration from them it's emotional and
bring me to another level of dance like
capacity how the human being can be
connected with someone life is not from
your country or not in your culture but
it's like declination what you have may
you feel strong and you feel bigger
amazing powerful and also give you the
cop - Mayday the way we're dance is
stronger and when you have a studio full
of people with that just profound
differences not just physically but in
terms of nationality in terms of
language and to watch all of those
people in the space harmoniously
supporting one another you have
something that flies in the face of and
who want essentially to drag us back
into a place where we can no longer make
human choices directing he
who ad program you in
[Music]